ce document a été postée sur les réseaux
sociaux il est attribué aussi d'ici le
centre pour le contrôle et la prévention
des maladies organisme officiel des
états unis en matière de santé publique
langage scientifique en tête de
l'organisme tout y est
ce document affirme que les masque en
tissu ne servirait à rien pire encore
ils pourraient intoxiqué leur propre
porter cette publication a été partagé
plus de 1700 fois à elle seule a été
consulté plus de 200 mille fois en deux
jours
seulement voilà il s'agit d'un faux
document que le signe ici n'a jamais
publié le document sur la photo qui a
accumulé plus de 200 mx vu en deux jours
a été conçu pour laisser croire qu'il a
été imprimé à partir d'une page web du
site ici mais que si d'ici a déclaré à
l'agencé ap qu'il n'était pas
authentique
le sis d'ici ne transmet en aucun cas
des directives ou des recommandations au
public dans un tel format a déclaré
jasmin reed spécialiste des affaires
publiques à lagence un examen plus
attentif d'une section encerclé du texte
du faux rapport montre que ces
directives ne correspond pas aux
véritables ou directives du cid ici sur
les masques alors non le masque en tissu
n'est pas dangereux pour la santé comme
l'insinuent ce faux documents le
s'initier a même publié sur les réseaux
sociaux long tutoriel pour fabriquer
soi-même un masque si la dangerosité du
masque en tissu est hors sujet il serait
cependant moins filtrant que la version
chirurgicale l'efficacité de la
filtration des masques en tissu
généralement inférieures à celles des
masques chirurgicaux et des respirateurs
cependant les masques en tissus peuvent
offrir une certaine protection
s'ils sont bien conçus et utilisés
correctement les masque en tissu
multicouches conçu pour épouser le
contour du visage fabriquée en tissu
imperméable avec un nombre élevé de fil
et un tissage fins peuvent fournir une
protection raisonnable pour être
efficace votre masque en tissu doit être
correctement fabriqué en france les nrs
l'institut national de recherche et de
sécurité avertit aussi sur le fait que
les masque en tissu ne fournirait pas le
même niveau de protection
les masques en tissus peuvent être
constituées de matériaux de différentes
natures
ces masques n'ont pas été soumis à
l'ensemble des tests d'efficacité
prescrits par les normes en vigueur
le peu d'études scientifiques sur les
performances de filtration des masques
en tissu montre une efficacité de
filtration inférieure à celle des
masques chirurgicaux lui d'études sur le
personnel hospitalier a également montré
que le risque d'infections respiratoires
étaient plus importants dans le groupe
portant un masque en tissu que dans le
groupe portant un masque chirurgical
le gouvernement français a fixé un
cahier des charges pour les masques dits
grand public car vous l'aurez compris il
ne suffit pas de se couvrir la bouche et
le nez d'un bout de chiffon
il faut aussi vous assurer que votre
masque en tissu respecte bien les normes
fixées par les autorités en cas de doute
opter pour la version chirurgicale